yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I
hope all of you all right maybe some
people coming back from yesterday's
simultaneous display which was quite
nice I hope some of you watched that as
well okay I'm going to play a couple of
blitz games as I do on almost every
Monday some five-minute games let's go I
hope the stream is more steady than it
was yesterday it was a bit a bit awkward
twitch had some big bend with problems
so at times the stream was breaking up I
had to restart it all over again okay
here we go i have requested a game
haven't gotten haven't gotten one yet I
said correct English I hope it is yeah I
know game yet that's weird can I get a
960 game maybe what else do we have 963
minute so let's see can I get some
five-minute games going doesn't seem to
be what's happening here nobody on ah
here we got Giga brain okay kicking off
with d4 and what are we going to get yup
yeah hi two grooms a and toujours in you
if you join twitch you can chat it's a
good thing getting into contact with me
can ask questions everything yellow auto
to just well and be be JH 13 so we've
got some kind of bug winyan here the
Giga brain is really taking its time so
going to take on the tour again pre-move
22 maybe it's really strange c really
re-inventing theory here can also go
Queenie seven or a 527 so i think ii for
as a possible move Knight f6 uh-huh hmm
okay 594 that's slightly awkward maybe
Bishop d3 there's a question how fast is
my internet connection um usually fast
enough for most ask why does the stream
statutory or something I've got I think
100 megabit down and five megabits um
upstream which should be plenty for for
a stream yeah it's not a real BOGO I
think
so here I'm going for 93 quick 95 okay
he's very relaxed about its development
is c5 something or maybe just I can also
put direct pressure on the pony with
rooty one it's going to be a bit
difficult now isn't it I mean Bishop c2
and then e five let's see what happens
I'm attacking d6 and rook GA to see Five
now hello also to buy you a shot right
sir yeah what about these six here yeah
not a happy move but maybe something he
had to do and I wonder if Bishop g4 is
something that could be annoying might
be i'm going to play at 3m I could have
played 94 now that I think of it but
just doing it like this centralizing
cannot be bad yeah here 95 is the
knee-jerk reaction already but I don't
know if it is so great at the at this
particular moment can still do that the
position doesn't change fundamentally as
the left more space yeah 95 from okay
let's do it
27 probably maybe it's not going to take
yeah so this is interesting now I can
play try to play something sophisticated
or something simple 94 for example I
didn't really help I've got no
particular tournament planned at the
mood i don't think i will play any
tournament any tournaments this year I
already played some stuff and they have
to work at work a little bit here and
down okay Queen on c3 how that's true
well Grimsey asked if I have why I don't
play the kalashnikov Sicilian anymore
and blitz there's no particular reason
one problem with the kalashnikov is that
people tend to avoid it by playing
Bishop b5 and it's something that yeah
I'm not a huge fan of okay I'm kind of
surprised here isn't this very good for
me here 96 so Bishop f5 night see 794 it
looks really awkward hmm
No
but how do I win this looks terrible for
black but how do I win Rookie aid piling
up it's not so easy rupee three Queen f7
seems to save the day I can go see six
if I once but I don't see how to how to
really decide matters hmm don't quite
see it Queen III is going to play night
XD for should be seven rookie 30 p 3
okay that might win the exchange just
sound okay so okay let's do it
I should win the exchange
looks good yeah I think Joe is on
schedule again soon with his been
tablets but I'm not completely sure I
don't have the the info worm on me maybe
check the calendar um so yeah I'm not
such a huge fan of books by of gayness
resnikoff I think he tends to be a bit
crazy about some things very dogmatic no
i didn't really chat to any of the top
players in Berlin didn't get the
opportunity but it was very nice to meet
some people that did I know from from
very long time that it didn't meet for a
long time that was very nice meeting
them again um yeah the games in berlin
did I enjoy them hmm that the problem
was that you couldn't really watch that
well the spectators weren't exactly am
in the the best of positions ok I'm
returning the exchange now to get a
simpler to play position the rook ending
here is also very good for me I think I
can be satisfied with that
it's a very very active position and he
cannot really move away his rook there
from c7 they didn't have they had one
big screen there but it was mostly just
featuring Carlton scheme and just one
game if it wasn't Carlton's game then
one of the other top four boards which
is not bad but ultimately it's not as
like watching all of the games I'm going
for meeting a check here now with rook
e8 NT lost some time ok yeah stretching
cough believes that one is six is a
mistake on e4 and c6 is also crap
yeah I'm this a question by Jeff well or
just whoo ja through will I don't know
how to pronounce it yeah if you live in
Germany it's a good idea to try to find
a local chess club we'd really have lots
of clubs if you have them if you're
living now in a somewhat bigger city
they will mostly be they will probably
be a real range of clubs to choose from
and you can fight clubs on the website
of the German chess federation they will
give you a list according to your your
place where you live ok playing a link
museum and the stang GUI 10 guy ring why
I think here from ring gua from belgium
currently living in the US i believe
pretty good grandmaster but it's not
playing somehow hmm
no no games no no move here did he abort
that mmm strange very strange but I get
a new game yeah I think he somehow
resigned hmm very weird anyway let's
play the real matisse mo wherever that
is um there was a risk there was a
question about my music preference I
have no particular style of music I
prefer
usually would be something that is
really a yeah mostly a play by them by
human beings I'm not much into like
techno music or electronic music or
something like that so what about this
year maybe I can get rid of that bishop
that Bishop is kind of irritating mmm my
cat's very slowish but get rid of the
bishop why not and now maybe like f6
make so that this pawn is not dropping
mmm I don't think linkman suppose afraid
he's a really good player maybe there
was some technical problem sometimes you
start a game and then you recognize that
you simply cannot play because someone
is at the door or whatever and it
happened to me more than once typically
the pizza guy calling or something like
that okie dokie this is a bit awkward
here Bishop to b4 when the night comes
to d6 maybe 96 queen bee 69 f7 Queen
before the night is strapped I think
that's actually the case
that's a question by rekhs can you
recommend solid universe let's set up
against c4d 493 anything but if I like
kings any defense tirage defense but
some opening kings and events not so
great and the same is about tirage um
yeah the the universal approaches they
they have their their drawbacks of
course so I actually lose the exchange
that's bad news yeah i think the king's
indian can be played against basically
anything and it's not so bad in in most
most cases tirage while the terror is
not just a great opening but you can
play it something that is very
universally a pliable is set up with
Knight f6 e6 d5 there should be seven
castles like in the classical Queens
gambit this is also playable against
absolutely everything and it's a that
has the advantage of being a farm one
solid then the then the king's indian
but not as problematic to play as a car
wash where you always have to deal with
those structural program problems that
that are almost unavoidable with the IQ
p or some porn weaknesses this is pretty
much the only thing what you can also do
almost without any any big problems
universally is a dutch set up a dutch
set up like the leningrad touch this is
also playable against basically
everything and i recommend that
sometimes if people want a dynamic game
it's pretty interesting okay efore is my
idea maybe this can help me know he
played cui g3 really playing this well
trying for night e 64 maybe hmm i don't
quite understand what is doing here to
be honest I mean b5 is not going to be
working anyway okay this 194 looks kind
of lame so maybe this of course I'm I'm
an exchange down for not much but maybe
it's giving me some chance to see em
okay let's push a form
I don't know I think I mean not that I'm
being very that I'm very optimistic now
but I think my position actually has
been worse earlier age five some stuff
is kind of interesting now h5 f3 stuff
Brooke a five so trying something on the
fifth-ranked okay I'm going to kick the
Queen away this is probably Bishop e3
huh very likely maybe maybe going from
h3 his piece is there Bishop on b6 and
rook on 85 ever they're not doing that
much now that's a very good position now
I mean not that I'm better but I I
really have active play if he goes Queen
g4 again no ok now I'm going at 3m so
cheeks down now maybe you can take
windey for for some sort of endgame mmm
check this going it's going to take
don't I have some kind of tactic yeah
that's how to believe that I haven't why
do I just have to go back check kingi
too lucky for doesn't seem to work ok
may i played this badly i already had
some kind of playable position again and
now it still seems to be bad shup cheeks
Queen takes just about her walls
what a weird game and blunder we have
five here nah I stupid no it isn't he
didn't do it he didn't see it or what oh
shoot my idea was so incorrect I can
help I can barely tell you what I want
to wanted to do want to play Queenie
five check which is just amazingly bad
so is that something that I can do here
look aged 6 something to irritate him
here all night a four maybe yeah maybe
it's got 13 seconds
look a six what is its this doing
actually a jig here hmm it's no media
hmm I take on f 2 root g 7 this is made
mmm he's threatening this to take the
capture there ok I'm going back Queen a
three would have one on time of course
but I still try to play good news this
is sometimes costing me points I hear
yes no check i believe no good check at
least now I one on time we I there's a
question about my education in english i
only had English at school but I was
always trying to keep it in in good
shape by watching lots of original that
movies in English reading books in
English and so it's it's it's some it's
helpful
yeah my rating has suffered a [ __ ]
that's definitely true had a bad bad
streak but I'm on a good track IAM in
the first games of this um this
broadcast k going f 3 i'm playing chasm
since 1987 so long time 28 years okay so
i'm going to cancel long here in this
game don't do that too often in the
king's indian but he had felt kind of
okay that's a question by Corus t is
there an age where it is not worth
trying to get a few title yeah the thing
is um said those titles um worth getting
a title I mean what what exactly is some
what exactly is the point of getting a
title it can be just because um yeah you
like the confirmation that you have
reached a certain level it can also be
good for business forming from my job I
certainly need to have some kind of kind
of title but for a pure amateur player
um it is not really something that is
immensely useful to have okay here i'm
going to try something interesting this
is a very unusual way of playing but i
think it's interesting here because the
remaining structure will be rather
favorable for white Bishop c6 I'm going
Bishop a form but he has to really don't
see what else okay Bishop a for you
might take a fork a key for
interesting okay let's do that later
yeah those titles are easier for female
players that's definitely true
there's a German question must appoint
cple demontage unfold in deutsche welle
net no nishiyama i avenged mind as good
as Don tomás de dum which means i'm
trading Queens whenever I feel it's
appropriate it's not a certain certain
preference in my plane ok so this is
slightly weak down porn this is not
really nice but I mean the structure is
fantastic I just have to make sure that
i'm not losing stuff then this end game
is simply excellent for for me so mmm
yep i'm going to take and 94 night
before maybe but i don't really believe
it does help much you can try to go form
on d 4 x f4 but i will take a c5 I guess
Oh interesting hmm what about a 3 just
83 here yeah let's prevent night before
and go rook t1 and yeah if the stream is
giving you problems let me know I'm
going to restart this the stream I'm
trying to go yeah but am I not almost
trapping that night if I do this the
night has no square is right look see
for I take it out of threatening rookie
one
that's a that's a very nice ending so um
how to do this b3 I guess pin and 94
next I could have played 94 immediately
maybe but this is good
I don't see how he will defend against
the Sun against them the threat against
his weak bones
so let's see how to do this it looks
great but how to win probably I can go
over to be seven and window five pawn 96
I guess so
his King will try for counter play so
what do I do now I can check their tigi
five yeah i think i'm going to do that
this is the safest way to play
yeah I'm just there the funny request if
i can say i believe that belongs to me
dr. Jones and yeah i would have to work
to make a make it a very thick German
accent yeah that's what is this from
this is from Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade right did he resign here this
guy he did okay I've got a good streak
here back on 2400 so Batman King Batman
King I don't know who that is it is
resident in age Hernandez from England
aha Yong Yong Chi didn't know him okay
g3 what do I do now ok let's go e5 and
Indiana Jones yeah probably that German
German villains all over the place
yeah i think that indeed tactics
training can be very effective effective
one very effective so on i recommend
doing that up to a pretty high level of
course if you reach like a very decent
master strength you'd also have to do
other things but if you start our in
chess or are not a very experienced
player then doing tactics training is
very effective I don't know what is what
is he doing he really gives me the
center here or what I don't know okay
maybe it's not that great I was still
going to play d5 shouldn't be bad really
I absolutely am I absolutely recommend
to do tactics or some kind of tactics on
any level actually I also I always tell
my students make sure to do like 30
minutes a day if possible yeah it's like
what is this that's the same an apple a
day keeps the doctor away yeah and I
think 30 minutes of tactics the day
keeps the blunders away at least two to
a point so M what is this looks wrong to
me somehow this kind of thing the night
here I can go III but I don't know
really is this right here III will go at
4i am I guess the night doesn't have
many squares it only has c4 here but
then Quincy five is some kind of a
double attack so if i attack that night
what is he doing actually hmm look at
five is a very weird move
okay I'm playing it anyway as weird as
it looks there are many many good sites
where to do tactics training I usually
recommend chest tempo but many other
sites nowadays chest calm is also quite
okay and the leeches tactics trainer is
also good so f2 is hangings so I can
take this hmm yeah but the Queen I guess
and now what a weird position my rook he
is awkwardly placed and the night is
hanging moving this night would be good
night be six or something he will take
hmm I don't really think him taking he
has such an issue I mean I've got super
active pieces maybe just back yeah it's
difficult to play this this perfectly i
guess it's just a very wacky position he
maybe you just play the rook see one now
or something for possible discovery
I really don't think that the question
of which tactics trainer to choose is
that important as long as you do it in
the first place it's the same thing as
with any any physical exercise the most
important thing is that you do it yeah I
mean if you go I don't know swimming or
cycling or whatever what you do is often
it's just secondary that you do
something at all is the important thing
ok I'm going rook f2 just trying for
Bishop g4 I mean if he moves the night I
have Queen d3 anyway so he cannot really
do is cover him I have a hard time to
believe that I shouldn't be somewhat ok
here but my development is whack here I
really don't know a very strange
position
yeah he's taking a big time out I really
don't see a great move i am here i have
to admit maybe some consolidating more
for Bishop f3 or something I don't know
it doesn't feel right to play such a
slow move but I don't see something good
for him yeah this sir okay so i can just
take King III maybe no he's going up
that's a surprising should be six wins
at least a big temple
now that looks winning what is this move
now I don't see it really he has no good
King move and I'm attacking this this
night yeah this one there is really on a
form queen before I think I'm taking and
Quincy five threatening rookie three it
should be enough
yes I can do this yeah just taking what
is that a better way to win don't see it
at the moon queen before maybe but ok
this this will win or not
hard to believe it shouldn't win that's
made huh yeah let's made doing a good
good string of wins here what am I doing
here that's pretty good huh won all
games what's happening here that's cool
there was a really weird game you want
some techno music I have to really say I
have to absolutely never never got any
anything that would closely be called
techno really nothing the German Chess
Federation doesn't have a minimum rating
I was a question about that now in the
videos upload to YouTube I don't have
the material score as shown at all it is
them another software I don't want blues
music but i'm not an expert in any way
sorry something good that i recently
discovered term for myself is some
british band florence and the machine if
you like some folk rock pop kind of
thing it's a it's good so i have a nice
position here with some space advantage
but you meet our boy so my opponent I'm
split Bishop f5 hmm i wonder if taking
ng4 as an idea takes takes Knight takes
maybe it's an interesting way to play
yeah the condition for reporters and
spectators were not good in Berlin
that's definitely true I thought I felt
that watching the games was really
difficult it was much in which month it
was much easier to follow things on the
broadcast compared to the actual playing
halt the best what is the best line
against the limbs of Indian there's no
clear answer to that but there's a
couple of lines that definitely are good
if you want main lines really i
recommend the Rubenstein and the
classical it's a funny situation here
rook f6 I can take player 3 and trap the
night I have a nice position here I
believe he allowed this 96 business and
other good lines against the names oh
okay why is he not losing stuff see
going if I 45 or what she just about
saving himself he with e5 Bishop g3 F
form cheeks there who weird and as a
question what I think about Magnus
Carlsen's throwing away his pen after
losing a game in the Blitz event um you
know I think it's good it shows that
he's really caring about his result and
he hated to spoil his son to spoil his
result it's very human and it shows that
he's just a human being after all it
didn't have such a great great year and
I think he really wanted to get the
triple title again while thinking about
his somewhat mediocre result in the
Blitz sometimes people forget that again
he had a very very good result in the
rapid yeah it was really a dominating
performance okay so Luke g1 maybe I'm
really irritated that I didn't didn't
win stuff here no I didn't share for
someone in Berlin well maybe that wasn't
was a friend of mine playing Daniel
house rot he I also played him sometimes
on the channel and I think last week I
played him in the stream actually and he
was playing there we are friends for a
long time so I was hoping he hit as well
and he did well actually it was a
fantastically strong event so when his
some score was very very much ok yeah at
least the night desk kind of off I'm
going to try to get some pressure
against the F&H porn with the night
being offside on b5 really weird would
happen to him maybe you can take on e2
for a couple of pawns doesn't look
necessary though now it's probably not
the greatest idea where the best place
to play that you can analyze games
afterwards hmm I'm not sure as you see
it certainly ok they have the integrated
engine analysis but probably other
service offer similar things I don't
know really what other servers do
because I'm really almost exclusively
playing on the assessee
um Bishop g5 rook g6 f four wins back
the pawn I think King g7 I can take age
64 95 or night at five anyway so I'm
going to win back upon the agree shock
is always good for some kind of funny
somewhat sarcastic comment you're right
so what about this 95 getting something
back here no I didn't play in the in the
events in the rapid and blitz
Championships because when they when
they announced the tournament they had a
minimum raiding requirement of 2500 and
this is just too high for me so I
planned the whole trip to Berlin as a
spectator and only later it become clear
became clear that I probably could have
played because they they changed the
regulation they're allowing more players
in but by the time I already had
everything set up for them yeah for the
tourists approach it was ok really
so I'm going to get the King involved
hmm you don't want that ok that was
stupid town I didn't really see that he
can do this Wow
you
94 strong this is not good this is not
good that's a stupid game to lose really
from this very nice position when the
night was only six that was certainly
good for white but I couldn't really get
this going I can try to flag him huh oh
no that was stupid I will certainly
manage him let's be on for a bit is not
his really slow but quick enough ah that
was a really pretty pretty pretty bad
loss IAM from a very nice position ok
playing in mortal
f5 hmm ok let's see if I can get
something going here Bishop f4 I think
this is a very decent line for white I
think a six is surprisingly good in this
position no not doing this ok hmm ok
just neither three is good developing
normally yeah I also would have liked to
play in Berlin but it simply didn't work
out also it was really an exceptionally
strong tournament I mean I don't really
think I would have scored it would have
scored too well them have to be
realistic about it yeah hello to z
nation chess so I get you prepare see
form
I'm going to play C for almost no matter
what
yeah at least he cannot easily place his
6 in this position mmhmm yeah i still
think white is slightly more comfortable
because of the more the healthier
structure I haven't watched porn
sacrifice no and I'm not sure if I want
to what I heard they altered many many
facts of that of the event and I don't
feel I would be comfortable with that
the marshal what do you should you do
against the marshal attack well taking
taking the pawn I'm not a huge fan of I
have to admit I think that the the
practical chances are really really good
for for black it's just much easier to
play with the initiative so my
recommendation is to stick with these
three lines and just be content with
that I know it's not very inspiring yeah
I'm aware that
that the pawn sacrifice movie is a
Hollywood movie and therefore will um
doesn't need to be or should be a
realistic portrayal about chess but I
think it's kind of useless to alter
facts about some event that was pretty
exciting the way it was and they altered
some things as far as I heard that are
completely idiotic daughter like why I
changed the the end of game game one I
mean they didn't play it like that so
don't change it yeah nobody would make a
movie about football and say let's say
they let's say the mega they make a
movie about the world championship 2014
yeah and they make a it's about the
brazil germany match nobody would think
that ok a 71 that's no good we make it
41 yeah that's this is useless it just
idiotic so just keep stick to the facts
in cases where the facts are exciting
enough yeah if you want to make it more
dramatic it makes sense if the original
thing wasn't very dramatic but this
cannot be said for most of the match ok
so I have a nice position here for the
exchange which I did not blunder I
really gave it away on purpose thinking
that I should have very decent
compensation here what is this a deal
rook to d6 I'm happy to take that for
night f7 it's not an easy to play
position for him anyway 96 is threatened
so he's preventing this hmm any other
things that I might be able to do here
96 group d 6 quincy a check
and I just do a three come on black
doesn't have any great mousse here
anyway at least I don't see them
let's see what in mortal it's going to
do it's not easy my nights are pretty
pretty strong or pretty pretty good not
easy to come to play move here for black
book 2 6's quincy age he doesn't have
many moves here really i can think about
quincy too by the way and just picking
up the pawn he's got 94 but it's not
helping that much Quincy two is pretty
good move actually but I really don't
know what you what you should play I
don't see a move for black that that
seems satisfactory
yeah someone linked she burning and
LinkedIn video in the chat to some video
bought boris spassky and he said he he
gained enormous respect for Spassky
espace kia always struck me as a good
character in mortal he's not moving and
maybe he's frustrated i have got a seven
out of seven score against him and this
is this won't improve him I don't see a
play will move for black it seems he
just let the clock run down yeah maybe
he's calling cheating with the iso see
Edmunds good luck with that they're just
a bad position what can you do I'm going
to play one more game and it was good
yeah i just lost one I think the one
before that or two it was pretty okay
another question by latvia 89 how much i
was a date top players practice hmm it's
difficult to say if they prepare for a
tournament or whatever they are
currently am currently doing um I know
that they do lots of hours right before
a match I just like a regular day job I
guess around around it no II didn't
accuse me of cheating it just just would
be funny accusing someone of cheating
was streaming for the ICC and I came so
I'm going to play this now semi Slav
very solid line came opening up the
position yeah i'm not sure if this is
right here actually to be honest this f5
idea maybe in okay it doesn't seem to be
Bishop e3 hmm I didn't expect this move
let's do this yeah that's the question
how can cars in his early twenties be
better than aren't with so much less
experience it's a matter of experience
experiences helped but having lots of
energy also just help and cars is just
just younger does he really want to draw
here that's kind of weird now not a draw
let's play a bit trying for Bishop f3
hmm that's an interesting
now it's probably equal anyway Brooke
you won or something now that doesn't
help okay and who do you think will win
the candidates in 2016 I have no idea no
idea I think it's a very open very open
open race I might even be honored yeah
you never know but i don't know i have i
have the feeling that Nakamura has a
good shot he really did improve and okay
nakamura lost two penalty today oh
that's funny shielding says Kramnik we
win the candidates oh well I don't think
he will play in the first place so would
be difficult to win Kramnik is not
qualified and I don't see how he is
going to going to manage by what kind of
qualification method and all the way
well I'm while I'm talking that
integrators kind of out playing me here
maybe nicely
Yallah camera always has the odd loss
against them somewhat weaker rating wise
players when Pelletier is a very good
grandmaster but anyway but it's not
that's not what you have to do we really
have to beat the big guys when it counts
and maybe maybe he has a short in doing
this at doing this I'm trying to operate
with night xf7 ideas but I'm not sure if
it's really a thready group dat can
probably play
hmm night over to be five or something i
don't really like my position here mmm
Queen doesn't have many squares his
Queen down can I do something with this
may be here kramnik may get the white
card wild card that's possible yeah
evidence in Russia maybe but I think
that probably crumbling will get the
wild card if it is Russia s villa is
qualified you will also be a candidate
for wild card and kayaking is also
qualified yes hmm so it will probably be
crowned neck in this case okay I'm going
to take play three I don't like it but
anyway maybe this is still kind of kind
of draws kf3
could be true maybe she doing that I've
Luke is three though maybe just rookie 3
covering this end having 93 up my sleeve
knight on f6 is not doing much this is a
one thing in my favor
okay the worst is definitely over here
in this position
hmm why didn't I think about this move
that was stupid hmm ok it's not a big
problem but I could have avoided this
so what do we have here threatening
Lucas III I think I'm if he wants a draw
i have no way to avoid it maybe i can go
age fri on something trying to get 0
nigeria blundered into that it's maybe
not such a big problem
94 I cannot blame
shoot now I'm blundering the pawn stupid
I played as well always keeping some
kind of pressure so of course the draw
with in a longer time controlled
situation but it's difficult with no
time I it's so kind of draws i think if
i get to trade oh okay I get to trade
nights
I it's just a draw rly
I'm offering him a draw no okay that's
how that was stupid move no I came I'm
going to win on time now I offered in
majuro i'm not going to offer it five
times or so not much that I can do I
only draw off for that once okay so I
want that on time so um when was the
last time a minha hosted anything for
freedom hmm that's a good question I
don't really remember probably some
youth amuse championships yeah I'm going
to flag if they decline a draw if
they're excited draw they say okay I'm
going to try to win it losing on time
they basically take into account so i'm
continuing i'm offering a draw once and
that's it um no i have not decided if
there will be an on icc stream this week
have not decided that yet i'm currently
really really busy guys really busy i
can show you i mean no i can i'll show
you currently doing my texas which is
amazingly amazing piece of work in
germany with paperwork and all kinds of
weird legal issues stuff like that even
even with a relatively simple business
that i'm doing i really i have no idea
what people are doing with a with a
somewhat bigger business yeah
some I don't know trading goods that
they have to buy or whatever I mean it's
kind of crazy him ok guys thanks for
watching the stream i hope you enjoyed
it I'll be offer tonight maybe doing
some other stream I don't know can you
show us your private information what
would that be I don't know have a good
time guys see you